I
I was speaking for
next talk is Ellen Chanel and is going
to talk about Conda the cross-platform
package management system for any binary
binary distribution he works at he's
involved with continuum analytics and
and welcome everyone okay thank you so
welcome everyone my name is Elon schnell
and there has been quite a basset the
this conference about Conda and I want
to explain a little bit more how Conda
works and what it does there's a similar
talk to this one that my colleague Aaron
water actually gave it sci-fi two weeks
ago in austin texas and the title of the
talk is Kandra respect from package
manager for any binary distribution and
that's the official talking theme in the
official truck is solving the packaging
problem so what is the packaging problem
so in the Python community there has
been a long history a lot of things have
happened have happened in
to try and solve this problem and there
was of course distutils first of all and
then Philip II be started the setup
tools project and then tarik [ __ ] it
into the distribute project and then it
got distribute got merged back into
setuptools again and now we have pip and
wheel formats but yeah unfortunately I
don't think that any of these attempts
from the Python community itself are
able to solve the fundamental packaging
problem and this is why Conda takes a
quite different approach to packaging so
in packaging and distribution there are
really two sides of the problem you have
the problem of installing packages and
building packages and users only usually
want to install packages whereas the
developers they build packages but
developers are also users so they also
install packages and conduct tries to
make this distinction very yeah very
distinct at the side of building and the
side of installing and the interface is
really the Condor package format and the
Condor package format is really
extremely simple and that's important
because when you have a simple format
you have a simple interface between
between these two aspects the installing
and the
building of packages aspect so how do
you install Python packages currently
there are many different ways to do that
say that py install easy install which
is deprecated now people use grip
there's also system level packages like
Epcot RPM and some others Python setup
you I install works fine if it's pure
python and if it's not pure python
things need to get compiled and often
you get these cryptic here error
messages that you might not have GCC
installed or even if you have GCC
installed you might get some errors
about some header files being missing on
your system and then you might have to
install some RPM and to python setup you
I install again basically when you use
Python setup ey install you are your own
package manager and yeah pip really only
calls out to python setup you I install
grip only works with Python and it's not
so great for scientific packages that
depend on Big C libraries libraries as
such as hdf5 so when you try to install
pip install 85 pie and you don't have
the hdf5 dependency installed which is a
SI system level package then you have a
problem Nick Coughlin from the Python
packaging authority
really says that when you're using pip
you are a self integrator yeah here's
some of the history with building Python
packages some of the problems i mean the
root problem really in my point of view
starts with distutils it wasn't really
designed for a compiled packages and
that's the reason why numpy [ __ ] this
detail sent but numpy distutils comes
with its own problems then set of tools
is really over engineered and very
complicated and does a lot of I would
say he evil things like it monkey
patches distutils and you have problems
with entry points and another thing is
that it wants to install everything into
either eggs or into egg directories and
that's the reason why you have this easy
install that pth file which adds all
these eggs or egg directories to your
sister path and this code here is
actually code from the easy install that
pth file which exposes like it exposes
the fact that in a pth file in python
which is used to add other directories
to the module search path you can have
actually an import statement and if so
if one line in that
pth file starts with import than Python
execute that code and well I I think
it's a bad that Python really allows a
hook like this in PGH files but it's
even worse I think that that set up to
now exposes this heck and builds all its
machinery around it so package maintain
errs hate having packages that no one
can install so I've been talking about
the packaging problem and Python so far
but I think the real problem is this one
so what about wheels well into the
reason obviously is that most of the
developers developed their packages on
either Mac or Linux and they aren't I
mean if I just look at the people in
this room I see many macbooks and people
have accounts on linux servers and if i
look at the company I work for we have
really only two people that know windows
very well and everyone else is working
on unix systems so that's yeah a
challenge and on the other hand most of
the users of anaconda for example our
windows users we have between sixty and
seventy percent downloads for windows so
how about wheels don't wheels solve this
packaging problem well not really you
can't build see libraries as wheel
packages you can't build the hdf5
library the Atlas library VT k all this
netcdf of these sea level libraries and
you cannot create a wheel package of
Python itself wheel is really like a
different version of these egg packages
that are installed into the site
packages there purely designed around
centered around Python itself also
wheels don't address the metadata
problem which is that on the server you
don't have
all the information you need to install
a package and it's installed its
dependencies as well on the pi PI server
there is an xml RPC api that you can
call from python and it will tell you
what packages are available and you can
query metadata about those packages but
one important thing that is missing is
the is the dependency of those packages
and that's the reason by PIP when it
installs something it has to download
your package extracted in a temporary
location then it looks at the setup py4
requirements and then it installs these
downloads and installs these other
packages as well and Conda does this
differently as we will see later it has
a the full index of all packages with
all its dependencies so really you are
still self integrator if you use wheel
packages as well there are system
packaging solutions Linux we have young
app get there is someone OS X Windows
but they are all different and you don't
really want to use a different tool for
all these different operating systems
and ganda was designed to be
cross-platform from the beginning it's a
single code base for all os's and i've
learnt at this conference there are some
other tools that have similar goals like
the source PKG project but i think that
limited to two eunuchs it's not okay and
and also the next packaging salut
but yeah so what is Conda and how is
conduct trying to solve this problem
Conda is a system level package manager
it's Python agnostic and the reason that
I think the Python community is trying
is struggling with packaging and has
been drugged struggling with packaging
for such a long time and well it's still
struggling and I don't think that the
current attempts with the wheel format
are going to solve these problems is
that they treat Python like the
operating system so you have Python
installed it's like their assumption and
then you do everything on top of that
but Conda is really going one step back
and saying well you really have to treat
everything on the same level whether
it's Python itself whether it's an hdf5
c library or a python package like h5
pie these are all Condor packages and
Conda treats all of these the same way
and yeah this allows you to have much
more flexibility you can for example
with Conda install Python itself and you
can install different versions of Python
Python 2627 Python 3 and so on Python is
cross-platform
yeah well how canvas course platform it
doesn't require administrator privileges
and it installs only binaries and
metadata is stored in a separate file on
the repository index and it uses a Sat
solver to resolve these dependencies
before anything is installed I have a
question so how many people in this room
have already used Kandra okay maybe half
so maybe I can show some demos later how
you actually use conga but the people
that use it they will know that when you
install something with conduct first
fetches some index files then it tells
you these packages are going to be
downloaded these packages are going to
be linked and then installed so
everything that's going to happen is
known a priori because of this index
file so here some of the basic usage
commands can install this packages you
can search for packages you can create
environments i haven't mentioned
environments yet but these Conda
environments it's really like an
installed prefixed with different things
in it like for example user the user
directory on a Linux machine is one
prefix or user local is another prefix
and you can create such prefixes such
environments in your home directory as
well and yeah
that what usually happens when you say
Conda great and you can give names to
these environments and also but you can
also give it the full prefix and then
you can specify packages you want to
have their like Python 3 or Python 2 or
be more specific about the version and
then install things into that prefix
yeah and you can always get help by
using the dash H option on all the condo
subcommands I was surprised a few days
ago at the conference that someone was
struggling with condo and it turned out
they didn't know about the dash H the
online documentation is not always up to
date but the help files the help text
that is kept very up to date because
it's right there in the source and yeah
you can install packages into specific
environments you can update environments
you can actually export a list of
packages in an environment and it writes
that you can just pipe the output to a
file and then you can on a different
machine install all the packages that
are listed in that file you can in each
environment conduct keeps track of all
the changes you're doing and you can
list the revisions and the changes that
have been done by all ganda commands and
then you can revert back to all the
revisions so I've been talking about the
Condor package format so what does it
look like
so a condor package is a tarball to be
zipped tarball and it follows this
convention here about the file name it
has the package name version and a build
string and well the tar got bz to
extension and inside that tar ball is
the whatever you install with that
package you have the lib directory the
include bin man shared directory
whatever and then there's a special file
the well a special directory with two
files with the files file which lists
which files are going to be installed
and the indexed adjacent file that file
is used for the repository index to
extract information about the package
this file format is not Python specific
and the metadata aesthetic and it's
important to point out that you can
quite easily actually create these
Condor packages with simple tools like
we are like tar basically I mean we have
this show called Conda build and it has
a lot of features and it helps you build
garner packages in a systematic way but
it's not really the only way you can
build these packages yeah everything is
Python agnostic a condor package can
really be anything it can be Python
itself in anaconda we support Python 26
27 33 34 and also
recently Python one point O is a condor
package actually there are three Condor
packages to for Linux 32 and 64 billion
one for OSX with the Python 10 and see
libraries our libraries dt our
programming languages language we have
built Condor packages for that no tree s
one contributor has built some corner
packages for for Pearl like propel
itself but then also pearl extensions
and yeah you can do that for Julia what
ever you like you name it ok what
happens actually during the installation
installation project in stelae shun
process of a condor package so well the
first thing that happens is that Conda
looks at the repository data figures out
what dependencies there are what needs
to be installed and then it downloads
the tarball it enters it in packages
directory that's a cache and then files
a hard linked to the install path and
I'll talk about that in a minute but the
reason for hard linking into the install
path is to save disk space if you have
many different environments and once
things are hard linked into the install
prefix then there are some little
changes like to the shebang line and
other things that are done with the
install package and it also allows to
run post install scripts it's like a
bash script you can run after the
install but none of that is Python
specific and finally the metadata is
updated so that Connor knows something
has been installed yeah and that's it
it's really a simple process the
installing of Conda packages which we
always try to keep all the complexity on
the building site and have the format
and the install process as simple as
possible ok I've talked about and runs a
little bit so one thing to mention here
is that these environments are really
completely independent installations of
everything and to allow that to be
possible you need to be able to create
relocatable binaries and by relocatable
I don't mean that you can just take your
installed prefix and move it somewhere
else that that wouldn't work because of
the things that happen during the
install process like rewriting the
shipping lines but by that i mean the
condor package itself needs to be
written in a relocatable way way so the
way we do that with the linking is that
we use the like on linux the origin in
the our path and there are similar
tricks on mackin on windows
use as well and well most important of
all we don't have to set the Python path
or LD library path you don't have to
fiddle with any of these things all you
really do have to do is add that new
environment or the bin directory of that
new environment to your path and that's
not really necessary either if because
you can just execute binaries in any
environment directly if you specify the
full path so here's an example we have
two environments here one called test
and one simple environment and in both
environments Python 341 is linked to but
only in the sump I environment sin Phi
itself is linked to and yeah on the left
side you have the package cash this is
where everything is extracted and doing
it this way you see that python is
actually only extracted once saves disk
space this way and however I mean these
environments also work on black cross
file systems but it might fall back to
breitung either symbolic links or copies
and hard links actually also work on
windows even on windows XP so yeah it's
also memory displays efficient on
windows but we had to make some
do some tricks to make that actually
happen on Windows the OS that link
[ __ ] function out of the box in Python
doesn't work on windows so environments
they can be used to test different
Python versions and actually these
Python versions are only the ones that
are supported in our like official and
account or repositories you can like
build your own counter packages for like
Python 24 or 25 whatever you like um and
you can use these environments for
development you can try out new packages
from pi PI if you create an environment
you can install pip into the environment
and yeah then you can pip install into
these environments as well and yeah
ultimately we want to make science more
reproducible by having these
reproducible environments okay I want to
talk a little bit about building so
Conda comes with an extension called
Conda build it's a separate package that
you install with Conda but it's all part
of the Anaconda distribution but if you
start from mini Kandra mini Connor is
this installation that has only Conda
and the dependencies of condon if you
start from there then you would have to
say Kandra install Conda build and then
you have the counter build command
available and what it does it creates a
condor package from a recipe or actually
it creates
several corner packages from one recipe
and you can specify whether you want to
build a package for one version of
Python or another version and obviously
if you run that recipe on a different
architecture like Windows then it will
create a combo package for Windows and
in this condo recipe you have metadata
and you have built scripts that tell you
how things are yeah what what steps are
actually need to be executed during the
build and you can apply patch files to
your source and you can specify some
tests as well and it it's really a
framework for building these packages so
what kind of built does it looks at your
recipe and then it provides the source
for you it extracts the source and sets
up a built environment translate the
script then all new files that get
installed into that bill prefix they get
packaged up into the corner package and
then things are tested
okay ya think how are we doing on time
okay maybe it's best to actually show to
show how you would build a condor
package and so I'm here is this
breathable well I can make it larger so
I'm going I have a recipe here for EM
for the macro language so in this recipe
it says packages and for this version
this is where the source is coming from
and for tests I just run these commands
and the build script yeah says configure
make make install and the prefix is
going to be the prefix where things get
installed too so I just run Condor built
and I give it the directory of this
recipe and now it's building m4 for the
mac and I chose this example actually
because it's not a Python packaged in a
Python package in the recipe instead of
configure make make install you would
say something like Python setup py
install and you would also have their
dependencies you would have Python as a
built in the runtime dependency in this
example it's much easier because there
are no dependencies at all we just rely
on the system GCC and the system c
runtime as well okay so it built
the corner package for m4 and now i'm
going to upload this to bin star ving
star is this hosting service for
packages so this is my account here and
there's no m4 here yet but now i will
say upload this package it's going to
upload the package i just built i'm
going to refresh this page and here's
emfor and if i look at files there's
only one file here for OS x 64 bit and
now if i say Kandra install sandal elan
m4 it will download em for from from bin
star and link it well actually didn't
download it now because it was probably
already in the cash that's actually
right have to make sure that you
actually see the whole thing so suppose
we're on a different machine which
doesn't have the package already built
then then it would download it well now
it's already installed so to say Conda
remove them for
okay now it's actually downloading the
package it's downloading it it's
instruct extracting it into the package
cash then it's linking it end mm4
version yeah that's the m4 that comes
from the corner package okay else do I
have here yeah this is basically sharing
packages with bin star and as you might
notice this is actually an MX package
Kandra package for emacs that my
colleague aaron has created in his
account you can also self host Condor
packages you just created directory
within sub directories for the different
architectures and then you run the
Condor index command in the sub
directories and if we have enough time
which we might not I could do a quick
demo of how that's done so and me so I
create a directory
pi data 2014 and now I created directory
OS x 64 I go into that directory I copy
the Condor packet of m4 into that
directory now I run the Conda index
command now you see these repo date at a
JSON file here and now I go one
directory up and this needs to be served
and we have a web server and Python
already we just say Python dash mne
simple HTTP server and now it's serving
now I say well now I have two in my
Conda our C file at this this local
repository to the channel list now I can
say Kandra search em for and here it is
and comes from localhost and you can see
here that there was a request made to
the server so it's really nice to be
able to create a repository of packages
with aesthetic web server with PI API
this is not possible you have to have
some application running on your web
server ok yeah Conda is completely open
source it's bsd license it has a mailing
list under at continuum that I oh
I would like to take this opportunity to
thank continue for paying me to do work
on this open-source project and thanks
to these people especially Aaron who is
now the principal condo developer Brian
fun Devon who is the co-author of Conda
from who is the developer of bin starter
dork and Travis elephant who is the CEO
of continuum and and thank you for using
anaconda and for your attention
thank you for the nice overview and good
sa very informative demos as they say
actions speak louder than words so those
are very useful so we have time for one
quick question are there any plans to
address the problem of course
compilation of the packages so I have
for example Mac OS X machine and i were
to generate packages for windows linux
and mac OS OS x is there any way i can
do it now or any plans in the future to
implement that well the package is for
if it's if they are pure python packages
you're a mac package will be the same as
the linux package and on windows because
the directory structure is a bit
different we have a tool called Conda
convert where you can convert this into
a Windows package but in general as soon
as you have see extensions this wouldn't
work anymore you have to really compile
or cross compile if that's possible
one more question can you can you tell
us a little bit about the vision that
you have with Conda because my my
feeling is that it's very accepted and
people really like it in the science and
data community yeah but outside of that
it's not I have this my feeling it's not
that much used so are you approaching
that or what it was I mean it is really
two things I mean there's Kandra but
there's also anaconda the collection of
packages that we from continuing from
continuum maintain and keep up to date
and make sure they work together and
those are packages for the scientific
data Python community so I mean if other
people would have equally well tested
things for other domains then Condor
would be probably more accepted in those
domains as well thank you very much I'm
afraid we have time for no vacations so
let's thank the speaker once again
you